et thierry est avec nous bonjour thierry
alors il paraît que vous êtes un petit
peu le souffre de la cinquième chaîne
j'ai lu quelques déclarations
le matin ce matin oui je suis le suit de
virus vous avez ce sentiment nous en
disant que la nuit on peut peut-être
dire des choses qu'on dit pas le jour
recevoir des gens qu'on reçoit pas le
jour où au moins les recevoir
différemment dix ans comment allez-vous
concevoir cette émission mais comme une
soirée oh bah c'est à dire qu on dîne en
eau en discute enfin tokyo
et puis ensuite on descend pour un
concert donc c'est un peu comme quand on
a passé une soirée aubin qui visez vous
à travers votre émission
je vise les gens qui sont les décideurs
les leaders d'opinion les gens qu'on
peut attraper le matin quand il sera ce
qu'ils sont occupés toute la journée
après et le soir qui rentrent chez eux
et qui s'écroule devant les séries de
l'a5 et sauf le vendredi où ils
s'écrouleront devant balmy j est ce
qu'il y aura des originalités je connais
déjà la réponse mais je pose la question
par exemple ce soir il ya à chaban
delmas qui étaient invités ce qui est
assez drôle de le voir au bas il est en
compagnie de julien clerc qui fête ses
deux ans de mariage
en fait il avait oublié excepté ces deux
ans de mariage et puis on lui présente
un sujet sur la petite colline à qui le
fait réagir ça c'est marrant il ya le
frigo rodriguez arias du groupe c et
julien clerc qui chante une très très
belle chanson sur scène au sous sol des
bains je crois que c'est une bonne
soirée
alors si vous aviez un seul argument
avancé au million téléspectateurs qui
vous regarde en ce moment qu'elle serait
t'il pour que ce soir ils soient fidèles
à ben de minuit passé ça ressemble à
rien quoi c'est à dire que quand on voit
bouteiller ou mitterrand sur les autres
chaînes on état qu il avait de la pub
maintenant il ya de la contre pouvoir là
c'est la guerre dit que ça ne ressemble
à rien ça veut dire que c'est tout à
fait nouveau c'est très nouveau
parce que quand on dit d'une émission
qu'elle ne ressemble à rien c'est pas
forcément bon ben on verra
vous verrez merci pierrick